they said this happened
without warning
[Music]
water cannon fired on peaceful
pro-democracy protesters
in myanmar's capital napierdo
several men stumble a smear of blood can
be seen
this is the first time police have used
force
to try to disperse demonstrators
hours later state tv issued an ominous
warning those who affected stability
should be removed but then the general
who led the coup
promised this time democracy under the
military
would be different
for a multi-party democratic system a
fair and free election is important for
the long term
of the democratic system i want to make
a request to all citizens
to listen to the true facts and not
follow your own feelings
if the hope is reassurances of free and
fair elections without a time frame
and a list of the military's plans will
calm the demonstrators
the current leader will likely be
disappointed
we don't want the military junta we
never ever wanted this junta nobody
wants it
all the people are ready to fight them
on the streets today the police were
armed organized battalions
waiting for orders at times giving final
warnings to protesters
to disperse or be cleared
[Applause]
the uk and eu have called for a special
un
session amid fears of a brutal crackdown
so far violent clashes have been avoided
you have the commander in chief
declaring that no one is above the law
uh but then uh violating systematically
their own constitution overthrowing the
constitution
uh putting leaders of the country uh in
in detention and under arrest in seven
days the resistance to the coup
has swollen swamping streets in the
country's biggest city
and beyond
[Music]
many today carried signs written in
english
a bid to get their message to the
outside world
the voices in this movement are many and
varied
with the monks march the workers the
activists
the students they repeatedly called for
an immediate return to democracy
a demand the country's generals are
unlikely to grant
siobhan robbins sky news